all right the corona virus pandemic is
dramatically changing our everyday lives
as we keep saying throughout the week
we're examining what this new normal
looks like including how we work
socialize and get life-saving
information the corona virus has forced
gyms and fitness studios across the
country to close to help clients stay
healthy some are offering creative
alternatives CBS News
Danya Bacchus shows us how people are
exercising in the comfort of their own
homes with signs like these posted in
gym windows around the country fitness
instructors like the Marshall family in
Sherman Oaks California have been forced
to change their workouts move their fit
box kickboxing in strength training
classes from in-person the family owned
and operated fitness studio is now
live-streaming classes family kind of
got together and we were like you know
what our clients want to workout and
they don't just want to go home and do
jumping jacks and go on a run they want
to workout with us during a time of
social distancing Virtual Fitness is an
option many are turning to from personal
trainers to national chains like Planet
Fitness offering workout classes online
in hard times like this you have to find
a way to evolve in the streaming classes
aren't just for adults with so many
children out of school their classes for
them too
let's get moving and have some fun we're
gonna start reaching all the way up to
the top sights like oh they are for
quick dance and strength workouts too
kid-friendly music Holly Fisher is
channeling her inner yogi while she and
her family hang around the house the
three year old is watching cosmic kids
yoga which has seen a 1000% increase in
their views in the past few days
fan Joanie a little something for
everyone as they try to stay active as
we are all encouraged to stay home Danya
back is CBS News Los Angeles